hey there folks continuing to drop these
little informational videos during pride
month this time i want to talk about the
word
queer specifically whether or not it's a
slur
because this is something that i have
seen some heated debates on even now and
it kind of surprised me now there is no
question that the word queer has in the
past
been used as a slur against gay people
specifically or the lgbtqia
community in general however at this
point it's been pretty thoroughly
reclaimed it's been reclaimed by the
community since
the late 80s so it's pretty well
established at this point many within
the community
identify as queer i identify as queer
some of the time
so it is very much a reclaimed term and
unlike something like say
the n word it wasn't created originally
specifically to be
a slur and to put down a population it
had a meaning before it was used that
way and it hasn't meaning again after
that
if you yourself are not part of the
queer community be cautious on using it
just because you don't want to come
across as if you are using it like a
slur but be careful of that you should
be okay